they're tough right now so this is
episode one 98.
we're two away from 100.
kai moved from there to here he's at the
table for the first time no no i'm back
you've been on oh you've been on once
before twice what episode was one
without you get out of here yes that's
right i forgot about that that's right
that's fourth time adam was running down
one yes and then
we have tyler here today at the table
what's how did tyler get in here i hear
i heard he said who's the most
conservative person in the office we
said gerard no
tyler you think tyler's more
conservative than gerard's 100 so we're
about to find out okay all right we're
gonna have a good time he's like a
closet conservative who's ready to break
out right knock it off yeah knock it off
but what's david doing back there by the
way david is just sitting there you know
with his mustache
yeah there was a door open a seat open i
just want to stop there yeah let's just
hold on
let's just hope when we ask to type a
you actually type a unlike kai i think
he's time he's intentionally wanted to
fire himself from there to get hired
here but anyways we're on okay we've got
a lot of stories to cover today yeah
kai's ready to bring some value right
without a lo we don't know who made that
shirt by the way we have no idea what
company it's a great conversation
starter that's what it is yes i've never
heard of branding i've never heard like
can you imagine you make bmws you don't
put the logo on it you ever heard of
that before one big guy's one big riddle
mystery creative secret he doesn't like
letting anything out what's it to you
though hey what's the banner yeah don't
worry about that it is what it is it is
what it is okay it's like the old guard
and the new books right here the young
we started off and i asked you guys what
things do you have strong opinions on
with all these stories george can you
bring me up a little bit by the way
bring me up a little bit a little bit
check okay that's good much better kai's
first thing he said is
uh hurts buying a hundred thousand
teslas okay so hertz not only files
bankruptcy but they decide to buy a
hundred thousand teslas in the largest
electric vehicle purchase ever which
will cover that yellen talks about
inflation that is not going away and
that they want to tap into the
unrealized they want to tax unrealized
gains in capital gains which is
something we've never heard of before
she's the first to talk about it at that
level jack dorsey comes out and tweets
out that hyperinflation will be coming
to coming soon to us and the world which
by the way this is not a regular guy
saying that he not only
runs twitter and you got a
square which is a 100 billion dollar
company saying that ricky gervais uh
said he wants to live to see the younger
generation get called out for not being
woke enough which you know that guy is
in a league of his own that'll happen
bill maher defended chappelle we got to
talk about alec baldwin what happened
there we got some stories with what
happened at denver airport when they
held a job for expecting 5 000 people to
show up and folks you're going to be
surprised how many people showed up at
this job fair that tells you how much
people want to get a job putin putin
calls out cancel culture
in a very interesting way and we'll talk
about that trump is hungry to go
head-to-head against biden
uh florida desantis they're trying to
cancel the hell out of him fauci this
was not a good week for fauci no
and biden claims he visited the border
then sackey had to clarify that he
simply drove through the border once
again
he's been to the border okay there's a
border let's go to the restaurant let's
address this number right here all right
anyways what's this and that's right we
you were the first one to look at us and
let us know we crossed a hundred
thousand seven we're at a hundred
thousand we've been asking you guys to
support us we wanted to get to a hundred
thousand
before
which is coming up next week we hit it
it's it's a big deal you know since we
crossed the hundred thousand i've just
been screaming out let's go brandon all
week yeah i mean it's a pretty it is by
the way you know what 100 means though
what's that three times a week we made
that so but do you realize like imagine
if you're at the hospital okay husband
and wife they just had a son the entire
time they know they want to name their
kid brandon as a four weeks ago they
were going to name the kid brandon and
then this often goes to writer and says
let's go brandon right now wife and
husband are sitting there saying brett
isn't so bad babe we can name the kid
brandon babe we got to change we can't
name a brandon we can't name karen we
have to come up with a new name karen i
think has uh
i think karen's officially done yeah but
you know i think brandon is competing
though yeah i don't know not as much
karen
number one in the country on itunes
let's go brandon get out of here be
quiet beat adele be quiet i didn't know
that pull up this
i listened to it yesterday i don't know
who sent it to me by the way somebody
sent it to me yesterday on instagram i
listened to it it's actually pretty
hilarious
uh uh let's go brandon uh wraps up i
already got it here i'm quicker than
david
there's no way in the world you're
quicker than david buddy well now the
audience can't see kai
what's it say is is it really the number
one
fox business reaches top spot on itunes
chart get out of here bryson gray raps
look at australia that's what's coming
if we don't stand up stop complying with
them
taking our rights it's time to man up go
lower
the the the rapper's name is who who's
the rapper by the way what's good bryson
gray
i think there's a couple people that
have done this song because i saw some
wow the one you said
alexander
i've never heard a song any of these
karen getting viral but this brandon it
looks like it's here to stay at him i
don't i don't hold my beer yeah okay all
right so let's get into the story i
think we're gonna go into the tesla
story first
go to page five hertz is ordering
uh 100 000
tesla in the largest electric vehicle
purchase ever okay that's a hundred
thousand tesla this is right didn't they
just go bankrupt like a couple years ago
yeah year and a half ago yes they did
not have a good deal we talked about it
on the podcast sold their whole fleet of
cars the whole fleet no no no not the
whole fleet 200 000 out of six hundred
and fifty thousand cards okay two
hundred thousand out of six fifty they
sold
um
that was right when the pandemic this is
an insider story it hurts us place an
order for a hundred thousand teslas the
car rental firm announced monday the
cars will be delivered over the next 14
months with tesla model 3 sedan set to
be available for rental in the us and
europe hertz also said it will invest in
charging infrastructure to support the
fleet the order is a big boon for tesla
although it has drastically accelerated
output
in recent years the company still sells
a tiny amount of vehicles compared with
giants like toyota and gm in 2020
automakers shipped shy of 500 000
vehicles worldwide as recently as 2017
tesla delivered around 100 000 vehicles
in total tom brady will start in an
upcoming commercial touting the new cars
hertz said so what are your thoughts i'm
going to start off with you here since
this is the story you wanted to talk
about what are your thoughts on this all
right let's roll you remember back in
when the when the when the bankruptcy
when they first filed for the bankruptcy
they they came out this big story they
were giving their compensation package
16 million to the top 340 executives or
something right and everyone was like
what the hell is going on right
and we read that it said they were
giving it so they would stay on in terms
of the terms of the transition period
and stuff like this i took a dive into
this yesterday
and i gotta say i'm impressed this is a
104 year old company they
the stock price was at 15 pre pandemic
the pandemic hits there it sinks to two
as the
at the low it was two dollars right they
sold 200 000 cars in the latter half of
2020. what also happened to used cars at
this time prices skyrocketed
up to 20 and beyond so here they're
selling a large part of their fleet
liquidating and and getting cash
restructuring the debt
and then they uh they went they were
delisted and then they came back and i
think yesterday i saw their stock was at
twenty seven dollars from two dollars to
twenty seven yes so thirteen and a half
facts yes you gotta give him credit for
that so smart exactly you're talking
about pivoting talk about take talk
about leaning down the organization and
really restructuring and stuff like that
you think how much of this you think
they knew
the chip shortage was going to increase
the car value how much of this was luck
i think i think there's definitely luck
but a big part of it also is who who
anticipated the pandemic so that's also
bad luck the other way so i think it's
just more
no i don't i don't i don't i'm not
disputing that all i'm asking for is all
i'm asking about is the fact that
there's nobody a year and a half ago
that thought the chip shortage helped
use cars to go up 25
that's insane that never happens so look
this is the great thing about business
sometimes you get lucky and i think this
is a combination of a good decision and
some luck together no for sure so now
why are they doing 100 000 tesla though
well but think about they're building
the charging infrastructure too and the
government is subsidizing ev
infrastructure are they not yes so
they're being subsidized and this is
also in europe and in the us well and
elon musk
elon musk is incredibly rich now because
of this right he's worth what 288
billion
he's
well past jeff bezos as well yesterday
as of yesterday
elon musk by far and away the richest
man in the world it was neck and neck
with bezos do you have an opinion about
this yeah i think look i think you did a
nice little case example on hertz
specifically but i think overall this is
a just a microcosm of basically what's
going on in the world right now
everything is changing and the car
market is not immune to it right
whether that's people quitting their
jobs everyone's out of the workplace
right now the great reshuffle right the
great resignation everything has
happened with that i mean kai i'm
shocked you didn't cover what norway is
going on right now every chance you get
you want to bring up norway norway's
going all green by how long right it's a
couple years from now okay everything's
going green everything's changing
um but there's one constant there's one
constant in the world for the last 20
years
and that's tom brady he's still out here
doing tesla commercials apparently or
commercials for her yeah well it hurts
tesla i mean this is what it is so
everything is changing other than tom
brady's greatness that's the message i
got here so be prepared he's staying
consistent so the gas obviously
um he got through the water in the first
half the other day yeah and he's 43.
four four touchdowns in the first half
making it seem so easy cam newton's like
sums up with this guy with the whole uh
benjamin button deal i tweeted out i
said benjamin button aka tom brady threw
for four touchdowns the guy's a in a
league of his own well he had a bone to
pick with the bears
is this the whole aaron rodgers who
called him i own you i own you and he
comes i don't know
that was last week
he says um he says um
uh apparently aaron rodgers owns a few
shares in the chicago bears i don't know
if you heard him saying that
did you hear him saying that that's what
brady said that's what brady said i saw
that aaron rodgers owning the bears
which he does yeah so what's the bone
typically no that last i mean very
rarely does tom brady make bone-headed
plays but last year
he threw some
you know
long pass on fourth down he goes oh
i thought it was third down like you're
freaking tom brady what are you doing so
before the game or you know you know
pre-game they were like tom
you know you lost to the bears last year
you guys end up winning the super bowl
you're good
you know bonehead play of the year on
your half he's like don't worry i got
something for you
this week he came out and just crushed
him how do you not love the guys by the
way the bat the
manning brothers what they're doing and
he said he says
he says you know i love playing against
uh uh your brother peyton and then eli
says you know i actually love playing
against you exactly beat you every time
in the super bowl peyton said hey tom
don't you have a curfew don't you need
to go to sleep tom's like it's actually
past my curfew i gotta go to bed that
banter going back and forth man these
manning brothers not only do they have
talent but they're all so funny they're
funny and peyton's funny
eli's got his style of fun funny yeah
yeah but but the lead is peyton yes for
sure peyton's definitely the face of
that person i missed the peyton manning
commercials those were great for was
progressive right
he's still doing stuff yeah he's don't
count him out tyler he's not he's
hustling don't cancel peyton manning
just yet tyler he is not going away okay
so how about we talk about the alec
baldwin controversy with one oh
yesterday was so interesting seeing you
and mario go at it because for a minute
we were thinking about having mario on
the podcast yeah and you pissed him off
so much that he said i don't want to do
it well he went to go find a gun
if you can't leave that stuff on my bed
the joke is towards what you said with
mario so let's talk about what happened
here with alec it's all over the news i
don't even know which part of the story
to read i guess i'm going to read what
happened then i'm going to go into alan
dershowitz uh how he defended it so
director of photography killed movie
director injured after alec baldwin
discharged prop firearm on movie set cnn
story a film crew member has that and
another one has been injured
as he uh
discharged a prop gun in new mexico
thursday director photography
helena hutchins 42 was transported to
the hospital helicopter and pronounced
dead by medical personnel at the
university of new mexico hospital tragic
event director joel sauza 48 years old
was transported to uh
christus saint vincent regional medical
center by ambulance for care rust in a
is a western film set in 1880 that stars
baldwin travis fimmel
and jensen echols uh eccles is what the
uh
movie is about now i want to tell you
about the story with uh what alan
dershowitz said is the alec baldwin
shooting a homicide this is alan
dershowitz for msn the evidence is
currently unclear as to how to do how a
real gun
with real projectile was handed to
baldwin allegedly with an assurance that
it was a cold gun such a verbal
assurance does not come close to
satisfying what should be the felsafe
standards regardless of what the
investigation reveals it seems clear
that the preventable negligence
contributed to the death based on prior
cases it should have been crystal clear
that no gun or projectible capable of
being fired should have been on the set
or anywhere near baldwin and any other
actors according to numerous newspapers
reported film productions still often
used real guns loaded with blanks
accordingly
these involve actual gun powder and a
cartridge that can provide a realistic
looking flame and spark burns and other
minor injuries are common but serious
injuries are death and death are unusual
it is likely that that the killing of
helena hutchins could constitute a
homicide that is a criminal killing the
remaining questions are who might be
criminal responsible for the killing and
what degree homicide fits the evidence
so having said that i'm gonna go to you
first what are your thoughts about this
uh look obviously the biggest question
is
will
alec baldwin
go to jail for this will he be charged
with
you know uh killing somebody well look i
think um
number one that's just what a sad
situation are you kidding me just that
you're on a movie set you don't think
anything other than you imagine just
coming to work today and hey everyone
get your set ready bang
okay so i think she was married she had
a young son um and alec baldwin gave a
heartfelt response to the family uh
there was a the director apparently shot
as well i don't know if it was the same
bullet shoulder okay
um
you asked the question what's going to
happen to alec baldwin i don't think
anything whatsoever is going gonna
happen to alec baldwin as far as
um
you know being charged with anything
being sentenced to anything i think
you know look look at the evidence
that's happened here he was quote
unquote given a cold gun i think the
biggest question here is
what the hell was going on on that set
you know they said that the assistant
director had previously fought was fired
because of uh multiple gun incidents on
a set that he was on um
why is there a real gun on se i mean
we're making movies here we're making
fake stories but we have real guns on
set so i think they use real guns but
blanks they put blanks okay so why are
real bullets sometimes they use real
guns though do they really absolutely
sometimes they use real guns and they
were also saying that the gun had
misfired earlier on three times it
missed fire so it looks crazy there's
been and i remember being a kid this was
probably in the early 90s i don't know
the year maybe like 95
but i remember an incident like this
happened i was in complete disbelief
and who was that person brandon brandon
lee you know where it was son where was
it it was at ymca where i was working
out at 1995 out of here that's the ymca
i worked out at in what year 95 yeah
that's the wine cellar glendale
california right off of harvard yes by
rafi's place it's it's it's like it's a
30-second walk from rafi's place that's
where it was all over the place brandon
lee when he got shot you literally
weren't even born that no okay i think
you were just born yeah 95
and uh but i remember that happening i'm
thinking whole
this is this a fake story yeah this is
this is pre
you know fake news and yeah
there's theories behind it that story
bruce lee's son was filming i think the
movie was called the crow
and an accidental fire farm went off and
brandon lee was killed like holy
bruce lee's son so there is a case
example of this i'd like to see what
happened in that incident i have the
answer okay ruled in the xnl death by
prop gun on movie set okay and then was
anybody charged charges
yeah look i don't think look do you
think look i know that this is not to be
funny or humorous but
where's uh alec baldwin made himself
famous re famous again over the last few
years playing trump
and one of trump's famous line is i
could go shoot somebody on fifth avenue
i won't lose any uh supporters so
look the analogy there is i think
he feels horrible like alex whether he's
charged with something or not which i
don't think he will be
alex baldwin has killed someone murdered
someone right and he's got to be feeling
the girl alec baldwin yeah alec baldwin
and um
just a tragic situation but i don't
think he's going to be charged
your thoughts well everybody keeps
bringing up the old tweet of his from
2017. quote i wonder how it must feel to
wrongfully kill someone and uh now he
knows um you know it's sad man it's
really sad but at the same time it's not
so baldwin was just an actor right but
he's also a producer for the film so he
bears some responsibility in that the
the uh the armorer for the film was not
qualified she was like 24 years old uh
and she said something like i don't know
what i'm doing i've not done this before
right now
yeah right she had previously given a
gun to a child on set she didn't know
how to load the blanks
by the way you know
you know this is a nice opportunity for
our good friend jarrah hutchins she
should get in there and start doing
stuff with hollywood that's a good point
well and alec baldwin could have gone to
terran tactical in uh arizona or
california it's where all the stars
train what is it john berthold from uh
the walking dead yeah the punisher he's
all out there all the time he could have
trained with the weapons for a week you
do a week's worth of gun safety and
you're this probably doesn't happen or
not to mention you mentioned the will
smith the clip yesterday about the fact
that one guy points the gun and he says
hey
gun safety is yeah
what's the first thing you do with a gun
when you're handed it you watch somebody
pull the mag out uh
run the chamber three or four times make
sure it's empty you watch them do that
and then you're given the gun and you do
the same thing you pull the clip out and
you run the chamber three four times
make sure it's unloaded i mean this is
it seems like it's common sense but
obviously
tyler you're a texas guy yeah i assume
you've dealt with guns before just the
way you're talking i mean uh just like
once or twice like that's it yeah i mean
not as much as probably i would like to
you know i'd like to go shoot more but i
really have it and it's everybody i know
every time i've seen a gun held you give
it to somebody you watch them pull the
clip out run the chamber three four
times and you do the exact same thing
and there's two rules you don't point a
gun at anything you're not ready to kill
and you don't put your finger on the
trigger unless you're ready to shoot now
they're saying he was doing you know the
pull out the the crossfire i think is
what it was called
you know so baldwin was baldwin ones
yeah this is an old western movie okay
you got your gun license from jarrah
yeah okay and no i think i also think
it's one of those trust but verify i
mean if i'm pointing something at
someone i'd want to make sure myself
it's a matter especially when there's a
lot of people there's been misfires on
the set earlier people are complaining
about poor conditions whatever yeah the
whole crew walked off yeah that's the
part that's the part that people don't
know the film crew complained of unsafe
working working conditions prop gun
misfired multiple times before the this
is daily while
wire story a group of camera crew
workers walked off the set
of rust to protest working conditions
hours before
that this is literally
hours before alec baldwin who was
starring that's crazy in and producing
the western fatally shot one crew member
six members of camera crew walked up the
set thursday morning after
days of complaining at long hours and
low pay members of crew were uh driving
to the set at bonanza creek ranch near
santa fe new mexico every morning from
albuquerque a roughly 50-mile trip
despite being promised hotel rooms in
santa fe corners were being cut and they
brought in non-union people so they
could continue shooting one person with
knowledge of the situation said they
also added that the prop gun that
baldwin killed hutchins would had uh
already misfired several times during
shooting so this isn't like this is the
part where it gets a little bit tricky
yeah cause it's not it's not just in one
time accident like if it's misfired
multiple times you kind of know okay
this this gun isn't as reliable this is
the definition of a double triple
quadruple verify here definition of when
there's smoke there's fire clearly there
was incidents
i'll give you an idea we did mafia
states of america right and we're on the
set and we're shooting we're going
through everything that we're doing you
know we hired a nurse you know we spent
four thousand dollars on the nurse that
was there how many times did we use her
zero not one time we had a nurse at the
location because it was an undisclosed
location to make sure people were safe
she sat there and she said you know i
have nothing to do i said ma'am you know
i appreciate you just being here because
if something happens we just want to
make sure we're ready because exactly it
could get ugly the situation that we
have with michael francis and sammy
we're just trying to be protect and this
is not a big budget we're not this is
not a 10 million dollar budget hollywood
movie it's a half a million dollar
budget we're talking about so the the
point with something like this
the point with something like this is
you know
here's if i have a conversation with my
son tico okay
and he makes a mistake that a
five-year-old makes yeah and he's done
it seven times and he does it again i
say you know better yeah you can't use
that execute you could use it at five
you can't use it at nine right i had a
conversation with one of our guys
yesterday
and one of my favorite guys favorite
guys that i do business with i said
listen
there's one thing you're not you're not
stupid you're one of the smartest guys i
know okay yeah so when you have a
reputation of being very smart guess
what you can't ever play mistakes
you can't like you can't play dumb you
yeah you try to play dude
you like that out but you can't play
dumb okay so what's what's the moral of
the story the moral of the story is this
we're not talking about a first-time
actor no we're not talking about a d a c
or a b or that guy you're talking about
alec baldwin and you're talking about a
guy
that you said the whole trump thing that
was going on four years
he mocked everything that you know if
there's if this was the other way around
so let's flip this and let's just say
because this is the best way to always
find out how these things work if this
happened to clint eastwood what happens
people going to say i think there's
issues yeah you've been on for a while
you're freaking dirty harry i mean but
what i'm trying to say is i'm not
putting it with that part let me give
you another one this happens to mel
gibson what do people say if mel gibson
did this if this happened on mel gibson
what happens to mel gibson it'd be trash
what would happen to mel gibson today
are you saying because like listen this
isn't your rookie year you've been
around the block for 40 years this is
this is this is the part with politics
that's stay consistent yeah if somebody
i had the guy from babylon be here
yesterday set dylan who's an absolute
start of a guy and he's a christian guy
right and one of the main their biggest
story they ever did is a story where one
of their biggest story they did is
they said the
donald trump this is a satire website
like the onion except for the
conservative side not the left is on the
left side so they got you know they got
35 million visitors on a monthly basis
they got 34 000 monthly they got
subscribers that people pay one of their
stories they do this is a christian
based
you know uh satire website the article
said
donald trump says uh
you know i have done more for
christianity than jesus himself okay
this is the story and it goes viral it
gets shared three and a half million
times not liked not
shared three and a half million times he
texted me this morning he texted me this
morning to
share with me the article david i'm
gonna try to text this to you
uh for you to share this this this story
just came about he says pat this is not
a joke
donald trump just said the following
thing okay this was it two days ago
three days ago donald trump said this
month
nobody has done more for christianity or
evangelicals or for religion itself than
i
said that's a true story this is a true
quote from trump what he said right okay
well he has but but but the point is the
point is i want to share this with you
uh david do i have your number or no
david uh
uh uh i just send it to you just put it
up so people can't see it
so here's a question where i'm going
with the story okay
stay consistent yeah if this was mel
gibson would you have played the same
position you played msnbc cnn and all
the late night shows that are defending
alec because to me
if it was a mel if it was a clint if it
was even throw vince vaughn or
libertarian in there how would you have
handled this would you have come after
him i don't know i'm not telling you yes
or no all i'm saying is i don't know do
you see them they're playing politics
with this they're they're doing whatever
they can to put the blame
on the the producer and the set not on
alec what they don't realize is the fact
that he is one of the producers so this
is a responsibility on
you being the producer so it's a it's
not a it's not a simple situation i just
came here i acted and we left what
happened before the complaints unsafe
environment all of these things if the
attorney on the other side is arguing
they're going to use this okay and and
then forget about the guys on the other
side that are going to mock him for what
he said in 2017 yeah and he uses words
again so so i'm sorry you this is carmel
catching up as well a little bit if you
play that card you have to be ready that
this is going to catch what's the
biggest thing i say about trump he keeps
creating unnecessary enemies i'm sorry
you did this to yourself alec and now
you're going to get some of it because
you kept joking about this now you did
this you're gonna be held accountable
for it now the question do i really
think he's hurt
do i think this really messed with him
for him killing a crew member what do
you think absolutely emotionally yes
absolutely there is no question about it
i fully believe the guy is devastated
with the fact that this took place and i
don't even think it's devastated from
the standpoint oh babe am i going to go
to jail like you're talking to a girl i
really think he's hurt i really think
he's mourning i really think he's
struggling with it
but at the same time we have law order
we have justice okay
in the the point you made yesterday that
uh i don't know if you know when you
talk about a guy like this an a-lister
nothing's going to happen to the guy
with an a-lister i actually agree with
you yeah okay we're on the same page
i think uh you know this has happened
three times there was another guy in the
80s that this happened to 24 year old
stutt actor that was coming up and they
shot him as well i don't know the name
he wasn't a big name it was before our
era in the 80s when this happened we'll
see what's going to happen here but if a
dershowitz is saying
you're going to be held accountable for
this there should be he's saying
someone's going to be held accountable
but he's a producer obviously he's a
producer
so if you were being too cheap to bring
somebody like they were interviewing a
guy that's a former
uh fbi guy and what he does today he
gets hired to sit in sets and making
sure everything is safe you're supposed
to do that on productions okay so he
said every time before gun goes somebody
looks and says okay boom boom boom here
you go good that's their job quality
control if you don't have that guy then
the liability is on you for not wanting
to have that guy so who is the person
who's the executive producer they're
going to go to that so i i think it's
not going to be a pretty sight but and i
also think that when when you have movie
sets where you're cutting a little bit
on costs here or there like you kind of
get away with it at the time but when
when like this happens or accidents
happen yeah everything is going to be
scrutinized and then it's just going to
be blown up too here's what's up bigger
ones here's what sucks about this here's
what sucks about this for the creative
that i just thought about so imagine the
creative that can't afford to pay alec
the money that they want to pay him yeah
and let's just say they're trying to get
a guy just just come and do a cameo just
come and do something basic here's a
role i want you to play dude the
standards for what's going to happen
with movies going forward is going to go
to a whole different level here's the
other thing that's probably going to
happen as well incidents like this with
the current climate that we have
sag
is going to over regulate like never
before the cost of what it's going to be
required to have on every single set
just went to the roof with this so the
small business owner creative is sitting
there saying freaking a expenses
probably just went up 10 20 and we can't
even afford it but we gotta do it now no
you can't play a game at that point no
you can't it doesn't have to be a cost
thing it's a competence thing if you
just you don't have to hire somebody
that's expensive to have someone that's
competent you just have to to vet them
and do your research and put the proper
systems in place you don't have to spend
a ton of money to do this you're right
and as this gets scrutinized you realize
that there were multiple failures at
every angle the 9-1-1 call the woman
that called in said somebody's been shot
turned and was talking to a colleague
while she was on the phone and said that
the assistant director had just yelled
at her at lunch
and by the way right this whole this
whole movie was just a cluster and as it
gets scrutinized you realize that it
wasn't just the uh the armor it was
failures at multiple points and you know
it could have been prevented which is
really what oscar just said something he
gave five bucks thank you oscar he said
if you if you handle a real firearm
you're 100 responsible to ensure that
there's no round in the chamber capable
of firing your projectile
uh involuntary or not that's involuntary
manslaughter is what oscar calls it
that's that's that's the firearm world
fully complies by that that's the rules
treat every gun loaded yeah treat every
gun as a team i mean
to circle back to your point there was a
case example this exact situation and
there was nothing there was no legal
charges that no one was held accountable
for that no not at that point look like
you brought up a very good point with
the sag stuff very good point it says
here on the daily wire
corners were being cut and they brought
in non-union people so they can continue
shooting so i think you're you're you're
spot on that they're going to yeah but
this is going to hurt the creative i'm
not supportive especially
i don't like that but unfortunately it
is
unfortunately liz like you know when i
was a hummer mechanic and
you would work on the truck
and that's what i did and you know the
the the my boss sergeant braxton he was
the motor pool sergeant uh braxton if
you're out there anybody knows him i'd
love to talk to you man it's been 25
years i would love to have a counselor
he was an e6 at fort campbell kentucky
we had a great time together we don't
know where you are we want to find you i
would talk so much to him as an e4
and he would talk back the coolest
cat on campus was him we had a good
community anyways so i would go there
and i'm like dude why are there so many
warning signs
warning warning says because some idiot
put his finger down and cut his finger
off
because something so it was like 75
warning signs so the military finally to
protect ourselves they just warning
themselves out by putting it all over
the place right to say okay we just
don't want to deal with this
i think something like this what what
what what sometimes like you know we
would do video we would edit and
somebody doesn't do q obviously it's
never happened here before it's never
happened here before with the cube
flawless team
ever and it's just a very peaceful
environment but
i would always come back and i would say
who did the checklist yeah why do what
are you laughing i look at david's lap
right there why are you laughing david
huh
yeah okay got it so yeah i gotta go q
see something we would do we would do
the test to see did you check this did
you check this did you check this did
you check this
i don't know i think this is a not a
rookie uh uh group that they're uh looks
like it's not a rookie group that could
have checked it anyways i think
before we move on i think bottom line is
this family is going to walk away with a
civil lawsuit and they're going to get
millions of dollars right listen man the
family
rightfully so at this point of the game
bro they're just sitting there like
they're missing a person to die this way
i mean come on you know there's ways to
go this is not a way you want to lose
somebody you love and it's so unexpected
you know it's not like the husband was
married to a police officer she was a
director a cinematographer on a movie
it's like goodness gracious yeah listen
condolences goes out to that entire
family nothing anybody says is going to
replace the pain but
our prayers are with you so let's
continue to the next story i'm going to
go to the jack dorsey story here twitter
and square ceo jack dorsey says
hyperinflation will happen soon in the
u.s and the world now hyperinflation for
people that don't know kai it's two two
months in order fifty percent yeah
what's the
increase month over month yeah but but
that's what the scholars have put it
yeah that doesn't necessarily have to be
the case no hyperinflation could be 10
15 but the scholar said categorically
it's 50 so they just kind of came up
with this number and we followed that
guideline but here's what happened this
is a cnbc story
uh twitter co-founder jack dorsey
weighed in on escalating inflation in
the u.s saying things are going to get
considerably worse hyperinflation is
going to change everything dorsey
tweeted it's happening he added that he
sees the inflation problem escalating
around the globe it will happen in the
u.s soon and so the world the tweet
comes with consumer price inflation
running near a 30-year high in the u.s
and grown concerned that the problem
word could be worse than policy makers
have anticipated it's one thing to call
for a faster inflation
but it may be surprising to some that
dorsey used the word hyper inflation
condition of rapidly rising prices that
can ruin currencies and bring down whole
economy so i'm gonna go to you first
with this one before i go to tyler and
kai well i think for sure no matter what
jack dorsey says on twitter i don't
think he's going to get removed or
cancelled from twitter that's a good
point i think no matter what he says
he's a level of research yeah
he's going to be okay
um adam real quick how did you get to
that conclusion yeah i think you know he
he knows that uh people are two on
twitter but i know you brushed over the
numbers
but i actually thought you'd be a little
bit more um i'm reading the story first
and then we can no meaning like you're a
numbers guy yeah and inflation typically
runs at what two to three percent year
over year two percent is a good level
okay right so social security was just
adjusted for our senior seniors we have
a large senior community well you know
this is our podcast
um it was just adjusted believe it or
not you're not joking yeah we have
actually a big senior community as crazy
as it sounds yeah i got stopped by 78
year old at the beach saying hey you
know i listen to every single podcast
you guys do
and and not only that she's a 78 year
old jewish grandma that's awesome she
said you're the only podcast i listen to
it happens to be my grandma
your grandpa whatever bro
um but the reality is they just got a uh
i don't even call it a pay raise a
retirement raise of 5.9
right there's no secret that inflation's
definitely gone up they're saying that
it's somewhere around five six percent
they're saying that it's transitory
maybe it's not transitory but i think
when you use the word hyper inflation
yeah so if you if you're typically
running it two to three percent and
there was just a co adjustment cost of
living at five six percent and now
you're talking
the definition of inflation is fifty
percent a month or a thousand percent a
year yeah hybrid we're not
hyperinflation it's not even close so is
it hyperbolic yes is it accurate maybe
not i mean and then who's been speaking
against jack dorsey um economist david
rosenberg uh kathy wood from r came out
and she said look you don't know what
you're talking about bro
jim kramer even said something as well
she can uh so that's a religion right
whether you're going to agree with her
because she talked about the fact that
in 2008 she believed hyperinflation was
coming because the whole uh alan
greenspan uh you know quantitative
easing that she did she said i ended up
being wrong yeah she walked that back
yeah so
um she's the opposite end of michael
bury just remember that so she's the
opposite of birth she's whatever berry
believes she's the complete opposition
baris shorts tesla she longs tesla right
so you just gotta know very big somehow
they're both very successful investors
they're both very successful but they're
very opposite religions i just want you
to know she's doing okay with tesla
right now i'm not i'm not saying i'm
just saying those are two opposites so
if you're a burri camp she's the
opposite the the point that i'm uh
multimate getting at is is inflation
here yes is inflation real yes is
hyperinflation here yet there's no
indication that that's here yet this is
all speculation this is him being
hyperbolic yeah and he's not gonna get
canceled for saying stuff like this when
was the last time you know that that in
united states we had
hyper inflation hyper inflation from
what i understand it hasn't happened
since the freaking civil war right
there's only been hyper inflation 64
certified cases in world history so it's
very rare okay i mean look at what's
going on in venezuela right now you
think that's hyper inflammation right i
think that's happening here i don't
think so but but here's the question are
you saying it's not possible anything's
possible okay so anything's possible but
but what you're saying is that it's not
going to happen this time around i just
i just so so why don't you unpack why
you don't think it can happen this time
around
you seem very certain about it and i
like it i like your certainty because i
don't want hyperinflation i want to lean
on your confidence educate the rest of
us why i don't want it either to be
clear but when you have economists
weighing in got it and they're basically
saying hey jack dorsey yeah stick to
your long beards and and tweeting go
back to smoking the pies and all that
stuff i saw this we'll take it from
let's actually talk about it okay so why
don't we think it's because half the
battle with every this is what i can you
put that tweet i just text you right now
with uh dorsey i said the this is
dorsey's tweet hyperinflation is going
to change everything that's happening i
said you have two groups here number one
many entrepreneurs and operators who say
hyperinflation is coming number two many
scholars and professors who say it's not
one is in the game the other studies the
game who's right we're gonna find out
okay because you've got two guys one is
the professors it'll never happen the
economist it'll never happen
dorsey's in it runs square gets every
data probably has more access to data
than anybody else in the world to find
out the transactions and the 10
different things that they offer there
with their you know credit services with
their you know payments you can find out
who's buying what at what point they can
see everything no one has more there's
probably only
a handful there's probably only 20
people that have access to that kind of
data as he does okay it's probably going
to be jamie diamond it's probably going
to be stripe it's going to be some of
those guys so it's not a guy that's
saying something like this that woke up
one day smoke some hash and it's like
hey hyperinflation is coming he doesn't
also seem like somebody who has wild
predictions and just throws things out
there kind of
about stuff like that normally anyways
don't forget that's the same guy that
also permanently banned trump so you
have to know that obviously you can't
say this guys so so you have to know
where his processing comes from but
hyperinflation i want us to go deeper
look why don't we think it'll happen
this time i don't i'm not saying that i
don't think it will happen i'm just
giving some numbers out there what
actual inflation is where the adjusted
cost of living is for seniors right now
and the benchmarks that you have to
reach to reach hyperinflation again
hyperinflate high inflation is here no
doubt we printed 40 percent of the
world's of united states money in the
last 18 months we printed what five
trillion dollars that's no freaking joke
i'm not downplaying that what so ever
right but have we hit fifty percent a
month we hit a thousand percent a year
we haven't hit that yet what if we've
hit a tipping point where that's where
we're headed that's the question that's
what i'm concerned hang on
hyperinflation by whose standards does
he does jack dorsey mean hyperinflation
at 50 month over month a thousand
percent a year or does he just is he
being a little bit hyperbolic but 10
inflation it's not hyperinflation but
you definitely feel it it hurts it's
going to hurt the economy it's going to
blow so hyperinflation by who's standing
okay yeah so then use the word high
inflation but to use hyperinflation like
we're using definitions right here right
right hey definite uh hi inflation's
here bro brace yourself okay cool i got
it by the way to say hyperinflation make
a good point because the morgan stanley
cio came out yesterday i don't know if
you guys saw this or not morgan stanley
ciao came out and they asked him saying
hey what do you think about the fact
that dorsey said you know hyperinflation
or stagflation he says those are you
can't use those words he says we're not
going to use those words what we do
believe is inflation is here and it
ain't going away anytime soon so he
didn't say what yellen said three months
ago which is it's just like temporary
it's gonna go away or what biden said at
the cnn town hall when he said you know
probably in the first or second quarter
of 2022 it's going to go away you know
gas prices are going to go back down to
what it is and then the guy asked and
says so some of the issues and he wanted
to border which we'll get into that
later on but morgan stanley cio agrees
with you
they don't think hyperinflation is
coming all i'm asking for is indicators
to make us believe that that's not going
to happen because what is the cause of
inflation what causes inflation printing
of money okay money supplies what else
is it two months it's the supply and
demand thing it's a supply and demand
thing what else is it
um
workforce workforce what else is it well
i would say the cost of goods obviously
s p exactly all-time highs there's a big
uh say that again s p and dow hit
all-time highs yesterday it's like why
why did they do that what is no there's
no access property access to goods a
bunch of stuff that are financed fake
success yeah credit credits debt all of
that stuff right that's that's causing
hyperinflation i want to read janet
yellen because before we continue with
this here's what janet yellen had to say
about inflation uh just yesterday or two
days ago yellen says americans have
experienced current inflation rate in a
long time haven't experienced current
inflation rates in a long time a cnbc
story many firms are experiencing a
shortage of uh labor yellen says during
an interview with cnn sunday the covet
shock to the economy has caused
disruptions that will be working through
over the next year
and of course americans haven't seen
inflation like we've experienced in a
long time host jake tapper
noted how inflation is growing at its
fastest pace in 30 years and asked
whether spending more money on biden's
build back better agenda will be pouring
gas on inflation fire prompting yellen
to say the spending on the bipartisan
infrastructure package and a massive
social spending package would be spread
out over the next decade tapper later
asked yellen when she expects the
inflation rate to return to two percent
levels which the federal reserve
classifies as acceptable she replied i
expect improvement by the middle of next
year
second half of uh uh next year is what
she's saying okay that that's her words
let me see if there's anything else
that's it okay i have two questions go
for it question number one do you
believe her
do i believe her what's she saying
absolutely not and question number two
do you believe that she believes what
she's saying uh
i actually think she does okay i
actually think she does because uh and
this is a smart woman this is not a
person that hasn't been around she's a
small boy she's been done yeah fair
share i actually think she does and i
actually think a part of it is what
you're supposed to do to make the world
not panic and overreact because the last
thing they want is for people to stop
buying for people people to stop
spending for hoarding going back into
that mode no that is not a thing she
wants for the economy because that's not
her job now i called goldman sachs
yesterday
just to kind of find out what their
thoughts on what's going on i said so
what do you think is going to happen
with rates he says well powell's already
said they're going up i said okay uh uh
what do you think is going to happen
with inflation it says it's here it's
not going away and to control inflation
the way you do it is by increasing the
rates right so yes
say say hyperinflation goes okay you go
study jimmy carter today i did a video
talking about is uh
uh is jimmy it's joe biden
jimmy carter 2.0 or much worse right and
we compared how many markers 10 markers
yeah something like that on how
inflation was how misery index was and
we compared from the beginning of his
administration to the time he ended and
we compared biden from the day he got
started to where it is today so it's a
very interesting thing
inflation during uh uh jimmy carter do
you know how i got nearly 14 yeah okay
during jimmy carter interest rates were
double digits cds you could get a 16 cd
talk about save that money yeah 16 cd
but it means nothing if you're making 16
cd and inflation is 14 percent you're
only going to your mortgage is 12
percent that means nothing so
here's
why
hyperinflation may not show up
this is when i when they say
hyperinflation may not show up here's
here's how i prone fisherman i show up
hyperinflation may not show up but
10 15
interest rates may
before hyperinflation shows up they will
control it by banking interest rates 10
to 15 percent slamming the brakes
slamming the brakes at the highest level
listen pump the brakes don't go finance
anymore anymore if you can't afford a
million dollar home and you can't put 20
down guess what this ain't for you okay
no more five percent no more 10 percent
none of this stuff just go back and buy
500 dollar house and come back three
years later easy money no free money the
whole fake money the easy money stuff
because money is so freaking cheap right
now it's ridiculous there is no charge
there is a part of you
correct me if i'm wrong because with all
the printing and the fake success
because you get worked up about this
there is a part of you that definitely
wants to see some things crumble some
things crash why would i want it though
tell me why i would want it because you
tell me how you actually made your
success the right way yeah so when you
see fake success you're like this but
but let me ask you a question let me ask
you a question so why would i want it
unpack why would want it
why would you want why would i want that
to happen
just so reality comes back to normal i
think i mean you see a story out there
that you put a hundred dollars into
shibu inu
some crypto coin now you're worth a
million bucks yeah something ridiculous
okay it's just so far fast
it's fake success it's fake money if you
made it the real way why would you want
fake the only the only time
where
you would want something like this to
happen is sometimes we have to be
reminded
by reality hitting us yeah and it hasn't
hit america yet i also think it's a
restructuring
of the people who can and know how to do
it versus that's one area but to me to
me sometimes
look we can sit here and philosophically
talk about 93 keys to success and how to
do this with money and how to do that
with money
sometimes it's simplicity man it forces
you to go back to simple concepts this
is not about quantitative easing or qe
you know qovs or don't spend more than
you have
it just goes back to basics so
america needs to be humbled a little bit
by the economy and the way we're going
right now people are thinking this is
going to last forever we had a guy who
we were working at valleys we both leave
valleys i go to the insurance industry
within three years in the insurance
industry i'm barely making six figures a
year within three years in a mortgage
industry is making 500k per month wow we
go to
per month i can i go to the bank
and i'm fighting b of a on a fee he's
two uh what do you call it uh tell him
is down he's saying i'd like to deposit
1.3 million dollars and i look at him
i'm like
he looks at me says hey pat
that's my mother he just deposited 1.3
million just give me the points three
zero you know 30k what year is this this
is the 2004 2000 2000 uh 2005. first
year he's in the mortgage industry he's
in a mortgage
he's making 500k a month you know what
jake you know what happened to that guy
you know he had four rolls royces parked
outside
you know he says i need four different
color for rolls royces living in all the
everything was financed guess what
happened you lost it all tax every
single thing yeah wiped out because that
was fake success
and fake success gets filtered out very
very quickly and it's going to happen
again but the direction we're going
right now when a jack dorsey says
something like this
and people say that'll never happen the
only reason i agree that hyperinflation
will never happen is because be before
hyperinflation comes you're gonna
experience 10 15 percent oh you'll see
there'll be 10 15 interesting there's
also something to be said about there's
so many people
that are
getting money or making money without
working right and here's
let me just finish this and i'll go to
you there's what happened to just hard
work in america i'm working my ass off
i'm working hard i'm working smart and
these i'm reaping the benefits of what i
sew now it's stimulus checks right just
unemployment it's crypto it's nft it's
whatever stock market it's my house just
appreciated 35 percent it's cash all
cash buyers it seems a little too good
to be true and when it is it usually is
it usually is but i think but adam you
know
that's what 80 million people voted for
oh you're going to make this political
now but that is what 80 million people
voted for how so he explained his tax
plan
he explained to build it back better but
this happened none of that had to do
with taxes though none of that what i
just said what doesn't have to do with
taxes unemployment the stimulus
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait trump
gave just as much money as biden stop
this doesn't have to do with stimulus
this doesn't have to do it no it does
but not taxes trump gave stimulus when
the entire country was locked down you
couldn't do
too stimulus you couldn't do anything
nobody could go to work i understand do
you remember in dallas we'd walk we
drive the streets we're like are we
going to say we're on essentially
remember i remember when i was worried
i'd have to have like a pass to
basically show
i'm going to work don't arrest me do you
remember that yes we would drive the
streets worried because all of the
freeways were empty nothing i did a
story one time i'm like look at this
this doesn't make any sense
rush hour april or when one this is one
of the first lasted three four five
months yeah these are like it lasted a
month we came we came every day to work
we came seven days a week to work it was
during that time but it was well so yes
the point is that is a different era but
if you continue like this here's what
will happen i'm with you let me explain
no i know you're with me but this is
what people voted for the people that
voted for biden are getting exactly what
they voted for this is what they wanted
so you have to understand that when when
congressmen and senators
get up and they say i'm working for my
constituents you know when they say
things like that like you know they give
a mansion a hard time a man says listen
do you know where i live
do you know where my down america do but
you know he just talked about the other
day he's thinking about leaving the
party i don't know if you read that
article or not the mention is leaving
the party can you pull out that article
about the fact that manchester wants to
leave the party but i'm gonna give you
the story here denver's airport held the
job fair
to plug its huge labor shortage
david i think your mic is on
to plug it's huge labor shortage and
exec said he'd hoped 5000 people would
come but only a hundred people showed up
to the job fair okay a hundred people
let me read the story too and we'll go
to what you're trying to pull up here so
five thousand people that are expecting
100 people show up to the job fair
um
dennis uh uh this long this long champ
the president denver uh connoisseurs
association said that the organization
organizers had hoped for five thousand
people to show up to the job fair which
he called a very lofty goal organizers
had wanted to fill out about a thousand
jobs at the airport but only a hundred
people came to the four-hour fair the
airport's labor shortage could be
contributing to huge airport security
lines as travel rebounds the airport
also
hasn't been able to fully reopen its
shuttle bus that ferries travelers to
the airport because of a shortage
drivers at its shuttle bus contractor so
what's the point here even if the jobs
are out there people are not
wanting the job because i don't need to
go back to work i'm chilling getting
unemployment what happens when the
people you've talked about this a few
times on the podcast from the people
that are making eighteen dollars an hour
to flip a burger the restaurant workers
you know the minimum wage jobs that are
making 20 bucks an hour what happens
when they're either replaced or their
wages dropped substantially right and on
top of that when we pump the two million
dollars for the budget bill and the
three and a half yeah excuse me two
trillion and the one and a half trillion
for the infrastructure bill when that
all comes through what happens when the
wages drop or they're replaced by kiosks
the mcdonald's workers the burger king
workers you know the the the people that
are replaceable by machines and the
truck drivers et cetera et cetera et
cetera what happens when they're all
replaced
or the wages ubi baby
are you asking us yeah yeah i mean what
what happened or are you asking this
does this know what happens does this
attribute to the inflation and to
like kai said a point of no return where
we could hit
inflation that's unstoppable maybe not
hyperinflation but maybe 25 30 35
listen there's a there's a community in
politics
like yellen who hate billionaires
they passionately hate billionaires they
hate the fact that these people have
that much money they hate the fact that
bazel what's it called musk is worth 200
and whatever billion dollars nearly 300
billion dollars they hate that a guy is
that successful they cannot stand it so
yellen says is the story here with
yellen and uh unrealized gains or no i
thought that story was somewhere here
page nine okay where's yellen saying
which by the way let me let me give you
one little i don't see the page nine
it's it's uh go ahead i'm listening just
before we move on to the talking about
there it is we're talking about the job
fair you know you know i this is just a
little quick case example you talked
about minimum wage 15 18 an hour 20 you
know i went to i went driving through
taco bell the other day you remember i
was out here eating my taco bell it's i
think friday
there's as i'm in la i never go to taco
bell by the way um
there's a there's a for uh help wanted
you know how much they were um saying
for you know employee x and for
assistant manager x do you know how much
they were uh offering take a guess 23.
okay go ahead
yeah that's what i get yeah yeah 45
grand or 50 grand a year for for the
lower end
these are just workers at taco bell
workers 20 bucks an hour okay how about
i i i had to like do a double take eight
dollars an hour for an employee and 10
for an assistant manager
those were the numbers i i i go
what
this is in florida in boca raton
deerfield like who the hell is going to
apply for who wants his job
you're hearing people that you can go to
taco bell right now take a picture of
this site
it's right there so do you think they're
worth more than that i'm just saying you
paid 15 bucks an hour i'm not saying
that i'm just saying if you're the
employee's perspective we talked about
this story being you know 100 people
shout out to a 5 000 and we talk about
expectations versus reality they're
expecting 5 000 people 100 people show
up
if those are the actually numbers we
talked about the fight for 15 15 minimum
wage that was actually on the sign in
front of ordering the taco bell i'm
thinking no freaking way is anyone
taking this job at this point so now
it's no wonder
all right
that they're not
taking these jobs because you can sit
home and make
triple that unemployment yeah
but but at the same i i know what you're
saying but the taco bell is owned by yum
brands
yum brands and you you have to look at
the ebitda i mean the ebitda margins
where they are if the ebitda margins are
above 20 percent and they're only
willing to pay eight to ten bucks i mean
you got to increase you the hour you're
paying it's a mathematical formula
they're sitting there saying what they
can afford to pay they're showing
margins to the guy that's buying the
taco bell so if you end up doing 15
bucks an hour you're not selling a 50
steak you're not selling a 20 steak
you're selling a two dollar
tacos with yourself how much margins do
you have but the person that's gonna
take that job for eight ten twelve
dollars an hour 16 year old kids they
can't
spell ebitda they're not worried about
ebitda they're like should i take this
job or not i'm not telling the kid to
worry about it
the kid doesn't need to worry about that
but the guy running the business does
because the number one goal of a
business is to what
to stay in business you have to stay in
business if you don't stay in business
then what do you do you got to stay in
business so what do you expect the guy
to do to go out of business no but i
agree with you where they have to
restructure so to me
you're you're cornering me the taco bell
owner to make the tacos price from 199
to 249. that's incredible
no problem but but watch this what's 199
to 249 how big of an increase is it it's
50 cents it's 50 cents which is what 25
percent
what's 25 increase on eight dollars
it's only 10 bucks so it's not like
they're gonna go 50. so watch this to go
from 8 to 15 is a 90 increase right so
that means my buck 99 taco has got to be
379 yeah that better get a chalupa for
that right so but 379 is a taco chalupa
is what how much is a chalupa i don't
know well you look like you know what
the president chalupa is i assume it's
three bucks four bucks okay if it's if
your four dollar chalupa all of a sudden
becomes 750.
no i'm not getting it
listen if you want to get out of
something for his birthday get him like
a dozen chalupas i think it looks like
happy adam you stunned the whole office
the other day too and you came in with
taco bell everybody did the double tape
yeah like did he really come in with
taco bell yes did you guys see him
dancing last night by the way for a 40
year old man i was so impressed
i think he was we've got a great teacher
rob walker
yeah we definitely we're going to find
out if he's a good teacher or not we're
going to find that if rob's a good
teacher or not anyways okay i used to
kill the bar mitzvah scene when i was
13. did you really though killed it you
know john john mason was one of those
barnett's but the difference between
john mason and i is the last time i went
to a bar mitzvah was when i was going to
bar mitzvahs at 13. john mason went as a
30 year old man hosting bar mitzvah big
difference you just hurt his feelings
that's fine you just heard him put it
out there
he's going to come and slash your tires
yeah my car situation well it's did that
get fixed by the way or no no i still
got to deal with that yeah have you told
him yet no
[Laughter]
john mason can't get mad if it's true
this is what this is what his career was
john now he's killing it just got
himself a g wagon and a white hurricane
is what he just gets what is a hurricane
hurricane lamborghini it's a toyota
avalon model of a hurricane is what it
is it's going to be all right
i saw him roll up in the r8 too yeah
maybe adam maybe you should go to more
bar mitzvahs as well and when i met john
was a professional bar mitzvah guy okay
so we got a couple questions here so
paul berez says the good part of current
nonsense is we don't need all the fast
food it is essentially poison imagine 25
to 50 of all these and other toxic
businesses slowly disappeared okay
that's paul's position
next one is uh smedley butler the third
says pat what if hype what if
hyperinflation is their goal what if it
is their final phase what if the people
have to be brought to their needs before
they'll accept the world digital id
system hegelian dialectic listen a lot
of people
agree with you and believe what you're
saying and we know what hegelian
dialectic is and it's a strategy that's
worked effectively by
big governments for a long long time so
i'm not weighing that out i'm not
telling you there's not a group of
people that are not planning to do that
at the top i'm just telling you i don't
think it's everybody i think there are
certain people that want to do the right
thing i think there's certain people
that think uh uh
are not coming from that standpoint but
i do believe
the people that are the puppet masters
behind closed doors have some things
like that in mind because they're driven
by control they love control and they
hate rich people they hate anybody that
got rich under this system because they
wanted to be
you know taken away from them because
they can't stand the fact that these
guys independently not needing the
government ended up being successful
i've said this before i'll say it again
a parent when they lose
the the the the need of their kids
saying if you don't do this i'm not
going to buy that when the kid
eventually gets to a point i says mom i
don't give a i buy it myself that
control is gone and a mom and a dad is
like wait a minute i feel like i just
lost my child i feel like i just lost my
child you didn't lose your child he
became independent these politicians are
thinking they're still the mother the
nanny state to say you need us you need
us and the people like i don't need you
i can independently take care of myself
just leave me alone let's coexist and
enjoy these every once in a while family
gatherings that we have every four years
when we got to vote for the next
president but outside of that leave me
alone well and the people that are
pushing these policies are phenomenally
wealthy within themselves pelosi's worth
what 350 million i mean she's worth a
ton of money joe biden is working one of
the best stock pickers of all time oh
yeah great her husband
one of the best stock pickers of all
time how when she has time it's very
she's she's a legendary you got to
budget your time like elon musk
seriously five minutes at a time by the
way real quick the gentleman who just
made that comment yeah give me that name
again
read this medley butler right that's it
smedley butler the third so there's
multiple smedly butlers running out
there apparently so smelly butler sounds
like the type of person who believes in
the conspiracy theory of the hegelian
dialect
medley butler sounds like somebody that
would never eat a chalupa
he sounds like somebody medley you sound
wonderful i don't know if you're my kind
of guy
well shout out
uh i think what is that do you see it
pounds and says i think we need to give
the left everything they want and step
back will the country decline and
possibly worse sure but the debate
between capitalism and socialism will
finally be settled here's a problem with
that josh no the debate's been settled
in 100
150 different countries and people still
haven't learned because they think they
can do it right so i don't think
it is about winning the debate or not
winning the debate that debate's been
already done
they just want to do it here because
they want to be able to control it
during their time fyi janet dillon let
me read that story on page nine what she
says she wants to do dems plan
billionaires unrealized gains taxed to
help fund the two trillion dollar
spending delay new york post story
president biden's two trillion dollar
spending package continues to stall as
senior democrats are hoping to finalize
a proposal on a new annual tax on
billionaires unrealized capital gains
let me read that one more time hoping to
finalize a proposal on a new annual tax
on billionaires
unrealized capital gains do you know
what that means
they made money on an investment they
haven't taken the money out the equities
on that house the equities in the
company the equities in the stock they
haven't taken the money out
janet yellen and biden wanted tax
unrealized gains that hasn't been taken
out by the individual which is
absolutely ludicrous i mean if if
somebody said this stuff 20 years ago
they always said you've lost your mind
but it's becoming a reality today
we probably will have a wealth tax says
nancy pelosi come from sunday the
proposal which is being reviewed by
senate finance committee chairman ron
wyden
a democrat from oregon would impose an
annual tax on unrealized capital gains
on liquid assets held by billionaires
treasury secretary janet yellen said the
proposal will likely only affect less
than a thousand of the nation's
wealthiest citizen i don't care if it's
a thousand if it's 500 10 000 leave them
alone they keep creating jobs i don't
care what their net worth is let them
keep creating jobs and have an incentive
to create jobs because if they don't do
what they do
you're going to take a hit and by the
way
again it goes back down to why a
thousand
why are they the richest of the riches
how about the person that's worth 40
million how rich is 40 million to a
person making 15 bucks an hour very rare
how rich is 10 million to someone that's
making 50 bucks how rich is a million
dollars to person that's making 50 how
rich is a half a million dollars cash in
savings to a person that's making 15
bucks an hour so what's rich rich is
only any taxes that you will not pay so
if nancy pelosi is worth 300 million
let's make sure we pet the taxes a
billion so i don't have to pay in any of
it it's always i don't want to
experience the pain
you covered this a couple of podcasts
yeah this was like a month ago it's
always the person who's just a little
bit richer than you that that's where
you want to start yeah
and the problem is it's slippery slope
you know what this reminds me of because
you'll appreciate this i think
there was a lot because obviously you're
in the life insurance world there was a
long there was talks about
because obviously a life insurance the
death benefit is is tax-free oh yeah but
but at one point they were proposing
uh taxing the cash value buildup within
the policy
do you remember this of course i do but
that didn't pass it was rule 7702 that
they wanted to eliminate to tax the cash
value and the second value or the pul or
an iul or that stuff yeah and it didn't
pass that it didn't pass yeah and you
know who was leading that elizabeth
warren
was that dol was that all that was that
but by the way the camp that's in right
now is the camp that could do that yeah
that's the camp that's in right now well
to to
our last friend was it josh i don't know
whoever he said well why don't we just
let him have what they want listen
that's the whole point of america is to
have
the debate to have the ideas and find
out which ideas are actually right you
like
gerard likes to say that democrats are
the gas and republicans on the brakes
and there's two sides of the eagle
wherever you want to look at it but
that's the whole point of all right this
is the idea i want to go with hell no
we're not doing the idea and then at
some point there needs to be a
compromise and that's the problem in
america right now is that everyone's
entrenched on their sides
let's coalesce in the middle by the way
the bitcoin community is uh uh uh
thinking that if hyperinflation happens
bitcoin's gonna go to a hundred thousand
five hundred thousand a million dollars
that's what that's why jack dorsey is
probably saying hi
very big do you really think he needs
another billion dollars no but he's not
speaker now here's the other part you
know peter b is a peter shift the gold
guy yeah she's thinking that gold's
going to take off with this and gold's
going to go to a whole different level
look the idea is the following this is
going to happen own
non-duplicatable assets keyword own
non-duplicatable assets very simple are
nft's non-duplicatable assets to that
it is as non-duplicatable as it can be
let me answer your question by the way
you said you think he cares about
another billion dollars jack dorsey
do you think he's a little bit
competitive
dorsey
so when you look around and he sees the
zucks worth a hundred billion but even
elon musk worth 200 something billion
the bezos 150 billion and he's worth
what is he worth i don't know i'm
guessing 10 billion i don't know
who he is one fourteen fourteen
you don't think he's a little
competitive saying i gotta get to a
hundred at some point but even even in
that case i think so he's not gonna be
the only one i think he's
not saying he's not going by the way i
love what rodolfo mayers just said you
can vote your way into socialism but you
cannot vote your way out what a powerful
thing to say you can vote your way into
socialism you cannot vote your way out
uh rodolfo that is extremely powerful
quote you just posted right now but yeah
i don't think that's what he's driven by
i just tell you it's this is let me talk
to the investor let's talk to the
investor the person that's listening to
this right now
is this probably a good time to own a
little bit of gold
maybe is this a good time to own a
little bit of crypto you know maybe get
a little bit of ethereum get a little
bit of whatever you know you
maybe
is it is it time to consider getting a
little bit of collectible cards or comic
books that are limited edition yeah
maybe this is not a bad time to
set aside some of those things that are
again
non-duplicatable assets if you do that
and hyperinflation happens it actually
favors you if you do that i have two
things on board which is interesting uh
first one obviously when they look at
people and you look at elon musk 280
billion dollars it's not like he's
sitting on a
on a pile of cash at 280 billion dollars
it's all invested in his company it's
all going to be taxed once he takes it
out once he takes payment and if the
tesla stock crashes so is his net worth
so it's not like he's sitting on it and
he's just kind of walking around with a
checking account with 280 billion so
it's a completely different way of how
that would then function of just doing
this and then the other part of it is if
it's just the thousand wealthiest
if they get it passed and approved
why not do two thousand why not do the
top ten percent like it it'll just
catastrophize you know just snowball
from catastrophic how many times do they
not promise if you're making less than
this your taxes aren't going to be
changed and then two weeks later
something comes out well maybe six
hundred dollars of taxes and that's
gonna change it exactly they have to
change because people like this is
pathetic if you're gonna come after my
six hundred dollars of taxes so they're
gonna they're gonna find a way to just
get it in the basement
we gotta deal with all this crap now
so they then they just say or we'll meet
you back at the 10 000 number yeah it's
uh maybe not we're we're good where
we're at
what's that what do you mean no with the
with the ten thousand where they're
trying to push for it and then it's like
so check this out here's what here's
what's happening at the same time right
so i had a a a guy came over the other
night and we had a con we had a cigar
until one o'clock in the morning
great conversations we had okay great
conversations we had to one o'clock in
the morning and the conversation came
about desantis he was a guy that worked
closely with desantis and he was an
advisor to desantis when desantis was
coming up again people don't realize
this guy's a 43 year old superstar right
now 43 year old superstar right now and
he's fighting but
the the left is trying to figure out any
way possible to cancel this guy and
desantis continues to fight back so
here's what story just came about okay
uh florida tries to lure ships waiting
at backlogged california porch this is a
story i think from last week if you want
to go to page eight
and then desantis is not not just
backing down and he starts recruiting
non-stop but here's what he says florida
is encouraging ships to ditch backed up
ports on the west coast and head its way
while dozens of ships remain more off
the coast of la waiting to be unloaded
in a historic supply chain scenario
ports and florida are humming
along with little or no delays and are
standing by if ships come ship shipping
companies decide to reroute freighters
to the east coast florida governor
desantis recently invited ships to
reroute and offload their shipments in
florida which has several ports we're
here we have capacity says desantis in
addition to rerouting ships some
recipients of goods that are being
manufactured overseas are also
reevaluating their ability to ship using
air freight that increased demand has
caused air cargo race to soar
to record levels but the sentence
doesn't stop let me go to the next one
here and then i'll open it up for
dialogue
descent is
planning five thousand dollar bonus for
unvaccinated police to relocate to
florida this is a new newsweek story
republican florida governor desantis
said on sunday that he is hoping to sign
legislation that would get unvaccinated
police officers a 5 000 bonus to
relocate to a state desantis commented
about police officers in other states
who are losing their jobs because they
are not complying with covet vaccine
mandates on a scientific basis most of
those first responders have had covet
and have recovered so they have strong
protection and so i think that
influences their decision he said
desantis called on police officers
across the country including those in
new york minneapolis and seattle to
relocate to the sunshine state if they
are not being accommodated at their jobs
when you play aggressive so i'm sitting
there and i'm talking to my sister
pauline and she says don't you think
this puts a target on him okay and i
said absolutely i said but what's the
alternative you're sitting there and not
doing anything about this you gotta you
get because if you think about who the
last guys that played this aggressive
type of offense was a guy named governor
perry okay and if you guys remember
governor perry where he's like you know
those three organizations you got the
epa and you got i don't know what the
shucks
you wanted to close the three
organizations it couldn't remember
anyways but here's what uh rick perry
did governor of texas he's who recruited
us to texas by the way i'm going to have
a sit down with him went to the rangers
game with him prior to that orion yeah
prior to abbott so rick perry comes to
california and he goes does a bunch of
talk shows radio shows and he says
if you're if you're a business owner in
the state of california and you're sick
and tired of being taxed and regulated
why don't you come to the great state of
texas we won't tax you we won't regulate
it we'll let you build your business and
do your thing but we want to welcome you
to the state of so he kept aggressively
recruiting people from texas from
california right okay
that's a bold move this guy's making a
bold move
he at this point of the game i guarantee
you there are meetings
non-stop
strategy sessions not how to save
america not how to deal with china not
how to deal with the border not how to
deal with the taxes they're having our
strategy sessions how the hell do we get
rid of this guy here that's why biden
doesn't have time to go to the border so
it makes sense but he drove past it in
oh wait you got to give him credit yeah
he drove you drove up close enough so
listen desantis
um apparently he's going to be rerunning
it's the conversation right now whether
he's going to be running for office or
not has to do with his wife's health uh
it's not uh you know it's it's a it's
he's she has breast cancer yeah it's
tough they're dealing with it but uh you
got to love his audacity to stand up
he's playing off people he is playing
i think i think another big thing for
this as well is you see
how many of us were talking about
desantis just
two years ago
he was an accomplishment 18 months ago
he was he almost lost andrew gillum the
social media i mean it was a close race
man florida would be in a totally
different position right now had that
race not gone in the favor of rhonda and
and i think it just goes to show that
during crisis certain people stand up
and certain people push back war time
leader yep big time exactly do you think
they're going to be able to cancel them
i mean it depends on as long as he
doesn't do is unless there's some dirt
on him that that they're going to
somehow pull up i think it's going to be
hard unless he miss
tell me who you can't find dirt on i
mean nobody you tell me who you cannot
find dirt on nobody okay then so do you
think their
research team is working and the
research team for them is who 24 7.
here's their research team folks working
at the irs yep forks working at yeah
forks working on social media sites
facebook instagram dms text phones this
is their research team it's a pretty
qualified research team by the way that
can get access to any information that
they want do you think they're going to
figure out a way to cancel the sentence
or you think you'll make it i think
they'll try but i also think that he's
not going to go down without a fight
i see him as a guy who's going to go
down swinging they're not going to find
something where he's just going to flat
out lay down and be like all right i'm
done i see him more going down with the
ship if that's the case well he's had a
target on his back for the past two
years since covet started since florida
didn't i mean they locked down for what
two weeks and that was it i mean he's
he's had a target on his back the whole
time and they've yet to cancel him like
like you said they're going to try but
he's he's not going to go down without a
fight david you look like you want to
say something go ahead colombia yeah i
don't think he
can be cancelled i think he's in the
same uh trump situation where i think a
lot of the trump supporters see desantis
as the second coming of trump
and so it's gonna be the same situation
where if he runs they're gonna try and
find all the dirt anytime he said
anything slightly
disagreeable and but he won't go down
it's not even saying something
disagreeable
strategy it's character assassination
it's uh manipulation it's
division it's gonna be family women
money taxes comments high school cancel
they're going to go and find a way to
get something on this guy here's the
question do you think it's there like i
don't think it's there with ron desantis
the way it was with trump trump had to
access hollywood tapes he has all you
know you i i could shoot somebody on
fifa
they'll find they'll find something oh
he's went to university of florida i
believe i'm sure he was drunk in the 90s
did something stupid women will come out
things happen he's a young guy he's 43
44 what is he what he's 43 september 4th
i think at the end of the day
whether you're on the left or on the
right you got to hand it hand it to the
guy he's doing a great job here in
florida and that's the key right i mean
he's doing a good job a lot of people
would disagree with that that are not in
florida okay but you got to hand it to
the guy and you brought up rick perry i
think he's sharper smarter more
aggressive um
just has better positions i think rick
perry was a a good old texas guy come on
down like i think i think this guy
actually is sharper than rick perry
would you agree he's actually actually
great impersonation right thank you
thank you i was just imitating your
impressions no wonder you were rick
yours was uh yeah exactly that was the
middle eastern rick perry
i think i think um one thing that
we um need to account for is
yes has he been on the
national stage a little bit but he
hasn't been on the national national
front page news
stage yet like trump i think the biggest
person in
desantis's way is not the irs stuff not
social not it's straight up donald j
trump
it kind of reminds me of when
tom brady was um
his rookie year or even when aaron
rodgers came and brett favre was there
you can use a million different
quarterback analogies santa's is tom
brady no meaning like you have this
young talent
you have this young talent who's clearly
talented politically yeah and is doing
good things and is maybe destined for
great things yeah and then you have the
old guard the bread farves of the world
the drew bledsoes of the world the
donald trumps of the world who aren't
just gonna get out of the way and give
the young buck the shot so unless
there's an injury unless there's a trade
unless he doesn't run
i don't think to say like desantis
as much as he might deserve the
republican nomination obviously has to
earn it
trump's not going anywhere
trump is not going anywhere trump is
going to be nominated to run just say it
i mean if you want him as your just talk
about it
i've said this a million times i would
vote for desantis in a heartbeat over
joe biden
i don't think the country the country
wants another four years of trump
i don't think
other than the base
we've done the trump thing again let's
get a young like i don't even want
another 70 something year old getting
back with your ex-girlfriend yeah you
know that there's going to be an abusive
relationship it doesn't work yes david
yeah are you dealing with something
right now
yes i just need a second okay who would
you rather have trump or desantis be
your president
uh if that that's that question is easy
question that's not the question though
what's the answer the question is easy
whoever is going to create less
unnecessary enemies and you think that's
the sentence that's the sentence he's
going to create less unnecessary and i
agree with you unfortunately the
republican base does not i think at the
because they don't think he's going to
get the nomination which is what you're
saying they don't i just think they're
they're all in on trump that's it and by
the way let me just go into the trump
story
because i don't think it's as clear-cut
as you make it i think the republican
party is fighting with whether or not
they can even go through with electing
trump we know what happened we know what
it did to the country culturally yeah it
was americans were better off than they
had been before 59 percent of americans
said they were better off you know at
the end of his uh term than they were
when it started but at the same time
we're well aware of what he did to the
country and the way it collapsed and
what has come because of it so it's i
don't think it's as clear-cut as you
make it that the whole right is behind
donald trump because they're not i think
it's going to be a battle i i wish you
were right i just don't think you are
well do you understand what i'm saying
so let me say this does your position
change depending on who trump's running
mate is if it's a trump desantis ticket
does your position change or it's
regardless is it
the point is i don't even know if that
is a ticket we'll cross that bridge when
we get there i don't even know if
desantis wants to
like if you're desantis don't you want
to do it yourself yo i now you're you're
happy you just kind of get swept in with
trump to know that a a trump tweet
helped him win yeah don't forget that so
a a trump tweet helped desantis win and
it was not it was very close you you
know this you this is your state yeah it
was very clear very clear trump tweeted
it out boom done deal by the way yeah
like the the arrows it was very close it
was neck and neck since then ronda
sanders has now been considered
potential next president 2024 andrew
gimlin was literally found like a
homosexual gangbang drugged out yeah
doing like not even joking yeah it was
bad like he was busting he didn't even
invite me bro
was he the one and was he did he join in
the one in hungary that we covered on
the podcast that time that was a
different one
good memory all right let me read this
insider story about trump since adam is
uh highly uh obsessed with the story
trump is hungry to go head-to-head
against biden for president
and can only be stopped by a
prison sentence says former advisor the
signs that he is increasingly interested
says david gergen a political
commentator and former white house
communications director served under
various administrations his interest
intensifies when he sees biden in
trouble when biden for example receives
backlash for his decision to withdraw
all u.s troops from afghanistan
prompting a swift taliban takeover trump
was really chomping at the bit gurgan
said three sources said that the former
president trump came close to announcing
the 2024 run in august at the height of
the chaos in afghanistan advisers
stepped in and convinced him not to do
it
due to a fear that his announcement
would derail the republican attempt to
take back congress in upcoming 2022
midterm elections wow
wow what a story right there too to
think that by the way trump had a pretty
good week with his spac when he
introduced the truth
the social media site that's coming out
he made
very very good money last week uh uh
with the spec and it's not slowing down
but going back to the store you're
talking about he can't wait to get in
the ring trump just cannot wait to get
back and he just doesn't want to say it
he's holding back saying we'll see if
i'm gonna run we'll see if i'm gonna run
folks if you're listening to this i'm
just curious i'm watching the comments
if you would if you would rather have
trump run on the republican side
type in the word trump if it's desantis
type in the sentence i'm just curious
between the two can you do a poll in
there or no
does the chat box allows you to do a
poll
all right then if you can do a poll do a
i don't know if you can do a poll but
i'll leave it up to you
um uh so what do you think about this uh
story with uh trump and uh
gergin saying the fact that they
prevented him from saying that because
they didn't want the midterms to be
affected by this who prevented him from
saying that okay so the three sources
said that the former president came
close announcing the 2024 run in august
at the height of the chaos in
afghanistan advisers stepped in
and convinced him not to due to a fear
that his announcement would derail the
republican attempt to take back congress
in upcoming 2022 midterm elections yeah
they're basically saying don
don't do anything to screw up that there
are inevitable
taking over of the house
you know what that means though that
means he's listening to people which is
new
i'm
he's listening to people mr adam he's
listening to your advice i think he is
chomping at the bit to get back out
there he sees blood in the water i have
a question joe biden sinking in the
approval ratings and he wants to get
back out there but there's no question
for him announcing anything until after
the midterms
will they run joe biden again
i don't think they would right that's
the question it's who runs against trump
so there's there's three questions right
because to piggyback real quick before
this what was the last president to be
in office and not run for re-election
when they could
there's from what i looked at this
morning there's one president in the
line of 46 presidents that has not run
for re-election there's a handful of
them that haven't won
but there's one president who just flat
out said yeah not for me who's that
and he gets hold on hold on hold on here
it's lbj yeah you could just said it you
just before i even saw it i was like
it's gotta be lb was it lbj
he's the only president but he he was
there for six years because he took over
for jfk
ran for re-election and then after that
he said yeah this is not for me he said
they were pulling out of vietnam and
they were um they were that he wouldn't
run for re-election i just i think
i hope that joe biden doesn't run again
in 2024. i hope he does a good job i
hope he leads the country the right way
the next few years he's obviously not
doing the best job ever
we need some new blood in there if i
were to make enough with the old
freaking idiots if i were to make a
prediction i think joe biden might be
the only
democrat that can't beat
trump
but he already knew kamala harris
connected again again by running again
the only democrat that can't i think i
think if if it's a joe biden versus a
trump yeah
then there's odds that he can't i think
if there's a new person coming in well
so here's my question where are we at in
four years or three and a half years
we've already got inflation we're only
nine months through this term ten months
through this term we've got inflation is
high they're pushing through the two and
a half trillion dollar bill they're the
two trillion dollar building
can't win china
rattling iran russia i mean where are we
at in four years
that's going to determine as much as we
want to look into our crystal ball i
mean whatever we could say anything
right now and it's like zero relevance
the reality is we've got to get through
midterms and then the election the
what people are failing to understand us
you know how hard the media railed
against trump when he ran the first time
and when he ran against this time
now you don't think they're gonna take
the january sixth insurrection wherever
you wanna call it and play that non-stop
and you don't think the ads
yeah they've already done that for
months okay but now when he's running
for a re-election you don't think
there's an ad that's just gonna show
everything and say is this what you want
from your leader you don't know how easy
it is but people already know what
they're getting with trump the thing
they don't know who he is and they
haven't
been elected last time exactly they
already know what they're getting
for the millionth time can we get some
freaking young girls
give a name on the left freaking the
rock
the rock tulsi gabbard in the rock i'd
vote for that ticket yeah seriously
finish the podcast right now we're done
joe manchin thanks for joining us he's
all over the news he's 74. yeah you want
fresh blood
[Laughter]
i don't know i think i think we have we
have time over the next few years to see
what leaders show up i want to make sure
was ron desantis on anybody's list 18
months ago no
but leaders show up in a time of crisis
so who's going to step up from the
democratic party we're seeing people
like desantis show up who's going to
show hopefully it's not someone who's
going to make sure you say your name
though say your name like a newsome like
a superstar like newsome for you well
news no someone
if manchin was younger he's the kind of
guy pete buddhich no not prickly pete
um what if it's not the democratic party
does have support i'm not saying i'm a
big better guy but he's young he's well
spoken he's from texas i know he's not a
big second amendment guy
but someone like a better dirt
better who eats dirt better is that yeah
he eat he ate ceremonial arizona dirt
all right that's my kind of guy kind of
man right there i eat taco bell same
so what if it's not what if it's
not the drama the democrats just so
everybody knows listeners needs to know
this this is not sponsored by taco bell
i just want you to know this is just
he's sure maybe you got a side deal yeah
he has one we don't know about that
chalupa 199 on the corner
i just want to say there's a new
grand slam burrito
drop the code name adam to get 10 off
anyways
do you not agree we need like
take off your your your republican hat
democratic just put on just your
american hat don't you think it's time
for some fresh blood
into politics at the head of tickets
78 year old biden 75 year old trump like
don't you think we got some young 40 50
year olds well you got 40 in ron
desantis okay and anyone younger on the
left like everyone just sees as
communist
socialists so no four i mean how old was
clinton when he got uh elected about the
same time 40s that's what we need
you're looking for
i'm looking for a young fresh someone
like that obama was young clinton was
young you know those two were young
uh reagan was at the time the oldest
president yep
who got reelected yeah so you know
uh but but also at the same time you
can't force superstars man they got to
come up like this dnc
they need a convention to have a obama
come up and rise up and give a message
people like who is this guy right so
they thought that the brothers from san
antonio the guy from san antonio but
they they lost the momentum
you know what i'm talking about very
well spoken you know but you know they
didn't get any support it wasn't like
anything crazy that happened with them
uh you know who do you have on the left
right now though actually remember who
was on the left when they were running
you don't have a great bullpen i mean
you had amy klobuchar up there that's
not happening right you had beto that's
not happening lizzie warren you had
elizabeth warren that's not happening
obviously you had kamala that's not
happening you had bernie that's done
don't forget about andrew yeah
started his own party
right and joe manchin's talking about
leaving the democratic party to go to
his own
article pull up the joel manchin article
i i think we're at a tipping point where
you could see a real change in american
politics because i don't understand how
divided they are you could see a change
from the you know you know what i would
want
whoever's elected whoever it is i would
love to have a president who has 60
approval rating
who's the last president that had 60
approval rates bill clinton george w
bush okay not that he was a you know
great
didn't turn
when he came into office it was
but that's what our country is lacking
there's a majority saying all right
just gave 50 and said the media creates
the problem stress anxiety anger and
fear with trump it's not trump okay
that's steve let's take a look at this
so this is what story this is a uh
intelligencer story is mansion
considering quitting the democratic
party go a little lower as the drama
with intrademocratic negotiations over
the build back better budget
reconciliation intensifies even more
report involving one of the story
central fingers on the bound to get a
lot of attention veteran mother jones
reported reported david corn is hearing
talk from joe manchin's associates that
he is mulling a party switch which he
will execute if and when he becomes
definitely dissatisfied
with his influence influence over his
fellow democrats the report was very
specific he told associates that he has
a two-step plan for exist exiting the
party first he would send a letter to
senator chuck schumer the top senate
democrat removing himself from the
democratic leadership of the senate he
is vice chair of the senate democrat
policy and communications committee
manchin hopes that would send a signal
he would then wait and see if that move
had any impact on the negotiations after
about a week he said he would change his
voter registration from democrat to
independence huh by the way when was
this story this was a week ago this is
literally last week and then manu rogers
says what uh mansion deny story is
considering leaving the democratic party
it's he told me yeah he added i
have no control over rumors and then
kelly uh ferris said knew joe mentioned
on if he ever plan to switch parties
tells me he made an offer to switch to
independent if him being a moderate
centrist was causing the damn party and
the issue says he would have still
caucus with dems manchester says that
offer was not accepted interesting and
let me ask you yeah where was joe
manchin this weekend
was he at miami with you he wasn't i
wish he was in the club with me kai was
in the club this weekend do you know
where manchin was this weekend tell us
meeting with biden doing a little vacay
together okay okay a little bit i wonder
though i wonder why biden wants a
mansion's vote that's pretty obvious and
he's and he's look do you know how long
manchin and biden have known each other
sure freaking 40 years
okay he's and this is what i've come how
long ago did i tell you keep your eye
out for this guy joe manchin
three years ago almost
you've been saying it for a while yeah
you introduced me to mansion yeah i'm
gonna give you and just because i used
to watch him on morning joe on msnbc at
the height of the trump stuff when it
was so easy for a democrat to talk
about trump he goes look
i'm not going to talk trash about the
president he just held himself so
honorably i said
this guy's who what's this guy's deal
and i looked into him a little bit he's
a democrat in the reddest state in the
country
understand the the his constituents
versus um his party and his allegiance
he's a guy who does what he feel is
right and and takes care of his people
he's been he's been a democrat for 40
plus years you think he's going to
switch over a little hot water right now
i don't think he's going anywhere i
think even if he goes dependent
independent he's going to caucus with
the democrats he understands how
valuable his vote is at this point and
he's going to play his card and he's
going to play it well you've seen that
this and a half trillion dollar
infrastructure deal has now somehow gone
to one and a half trillion just because
he said that's what i'm going for
every sentence he says is worth like a
hundred million dollars well don't
forget about christian cinema as well
that's true but um
she's a little more of a wild guard than
him but
he's a g he's a g and i i don't is the
whole point that you think he's going to
leave the democratic party
or do i think he's going to leave yeah
no i think the meeting with uh biden is
okay so let's actually process this yes
what happens if he says i'm leaving and
it goes independent is it a black eye
is it a story yes of course tell me why
it's a black guy well he's the number
one senator in the news right now i
don't think that's saying hey look i
don't like why is that a big deal is
that a bad look for biden yes how is it
a bad look for biden because it's
somebody leaving the democratic party so
let's go to what is the media going to
spin it what's the media going to say
they're going to say he's over it or
he's trying to become like because he is
the roadblock now that's stopping all
this so that would make it more sense
now the democrats unified and he's now
the rogue democrats you know you know
how some of these uh
superstars when they get a divorce with
their husband they'll have somebody on
the media spill a story saying the fact
that the husband was cheating right and
all along maybe it was the other way
around okay i mean this happens all the
time right so they're going to go to the
pr guy and what is the story that
they're all going to be on the same page
with if mansion leaves
he's a traitor
i don't think they're going to take that
position
i think they're going to take it more as
you know uh uh you know this guy's never
been a democrat
he's never he's been a closet republican
yeah this has been coming for a long
time and he has lost his touch with the
people you know he they're going to
spend he's getting old he's getting
they're going to make something about
that performance i don't think it's
going to be that big of a deal if he
leaves or not by the way no i think he's
a little bit of a black guy one week two
weeks gone and he's done well i think
for him though he he wields more power
within the democratic party i actually
agree with you so if his whole thing is
safe in america and i want to be i don't
know i want to be able to influence my
fellow democrats it's way stronger to
stay in no question about it as opposed
to and by the way it's like how a lot of
people like every like the birthday
party when people were over a lot of the
friends that were here from florida
guess what they're all saying when the
conversation comes up about desantis and
trump guess what they say i hope the
santas doesn't run
no nobody in florida
wants to send not nobody let me restate
most of the people who live in florida
don't want this guy to run because
they're worried who's going to replace
him they want to stay governor florida
we want him to stay
who will replace him that's a good point
that's the biggest concern so they do
not want him to run for president by the
way the democrats would be absolute
fools to talk any trash about joe
manchin let's say they do something to
piss him off and he doesn't want to run
for reelection again you know who gets
voted in right there
a hundred percent of republican senator
they flipped the seat okay they flip
that like if if i'm joe biden and if i'm
the dnc i'm doing everything to make
sure joe manchin's having a wonderful
freaking day today
by the way and i don't even even if he
leaves the party and becomes an
independent
do you know there's two senate senators
that are independent that caucus with
the democrats right now if he does in
the party who are the two senators
freaking bernie
independent he's a democrat though and
then angus king from maine
there's two independents already that
caucus with democrats so i think this is
just
nonsense i don't think mansion's going
anywhere i think at the end of the day
they got to get a deal done and they're
going to do the reconciliation package
whatever that is where you have 50 votes
and kamala's gonna um
you know bump it over and they just got
to work on
mansion which they're currently working
on and then you get this girl cinnamon i
i think it's a bigger deal than that i
think it's it's exactly descriptive of
the infighting within the party are they
going to go the aoc rashida talib ilhan
omar bernie route are they going to go
the joe manchin moderate christian
cinema route i mean i think it's so what
happens if
when when the jail mansions are out and
you've got the new blood where does the
democratic party go and i think this is
illustrative of that and they're
fighting for the face of the percentage
of the democrats do you think are
rashida talib type people aoc i don't
think what percentage i don't think it's
a big percentage i think it's maybe 20
but they're the last 15
they're the loudest correct you're right
they're going to just drag everything
more that direction right exactly i mean
kamala harris was the farthest left
senator in the senate before she got
elected she was even farther left than
bernie sanders was and i think this is
illustrative of the in far fighting
within the party
by the way people are commenting all
this stuff you know pbd for governor all
this stuff the one thing that i will say
is which i appreciate but i will say the
one that says francis suarez would
replace desantis as a governor he would
be very interested yes if he ran by the
way
but i wouldn't run for president if i'm
desantis if i'm not certain that suarez
is not going to run
if suarez is not running governor i'm
not sure if i want him running for by
the way you i mean you've met francis
soros stop interviewing him a few times
absolute stud
republican you know he said um
he gave a speech he's spoken
low regulation he said um
he goes something to the effect of um
when you're a mayor
you know you don't it doesn't matter if
you're republican or democrat you just
want to get done in your community
and that's the power of being a mayor he
said there's there's
talked about just being independent and
he's killing it in miami right now he's
making national waves he's a young stud
he's probably in his
mid-40s at the oldest
he just watch out for him he's going to
make a mistake great francis suarez i
mean listen if not him maybe jorge has
withdoll who
knows say something to me and knock
their asses out can you imagine what did
you say let's get done
democrat governor knocked out by jorge
masvidal jorge masvidal is asked to
remove from the election however he is
by far the most popular candidate ever
to run for the state of florida i think
uh usman would have something to say to
him about that i can see you reading
that story pat let's read this story
that's a satire by the way
oh my gosh okay so do we want to give
some love to uh fauci oh no let's go to
putin let's go to putin listen
i have i got to tell you guys this story
i was telling you this yesterday but i
think it's important for people to know
this friends and family who are russian
okay who live in america okay i don't
know i'm telling you this right now and
i know a lot i don't know a single
person will hit that i don't know a
single person
who's russian
doesn't respect and love putin it's such
a weird dynamic why do you think they
love it they love the way he leads he's
a man's man better putin than perry says
something about you maybe you're
watching too many of his videos okay
putin rails against cancer culture and
suggests teaching gender fluidity to
kids is a crime against humanity this is
an insider story
he took aim at cancer culture and
support as a transgender right
suggesting that teaching kids
teaching gender fluidity is a crime
against humanity while stating that
russia should remain its spiritual
values and historical traditions putin
said that some westerners believe the
aggressive deletion of whole pages of
their own history reverse discrimination
against the majority
in the interest of minorities constitute
movement toward public renewal let me
read that one more time what a technical
statement tongue twister listen to this
putin said that some westerners believe
the aggressive deletion
of whole pages of their own
history reverse discrimination against a
majority in the interests of minorities
constitute movement towards public
renewal
wow the russian leader whose opponents
have often ended up dead or imprisoned
likened cancer culture
to reverse racism he said the
emphasizing of the racial topic divides
people
um i'll go to you first and you know
what you have to say about what putin
just said right now oh well you know how
anthony fauci was voted uh
sexiest man alive i think putin's one
sexiest man alive in russia for like the
last 20 years in a row shirtless bear
pictures yeah so um
as much as i have
i'm not a fan of putin to put it in his
language he does have a point here so uh
look he's talking about ultimate
machismo why do you think he's elected
sexiest man alive in russia it's not
because he's actually that good looking
because he gives off that i protect the
country i take care of you and there's a
lot of people that actually empathize
with that i assume that's why your
family loves them so much um but what's
putin's motivation
like if you like forget about this whole
thing putin wants to empower russia and
so discord in the united states or in
the eu or nato he's not a friend to
america he's not a friend of us so
anything that comes out of his mouth i'm
thinking
what's in it for him
so i think he's just looking to uh so
discord in the united states he's not a
friend to america i think we also wait
so you're saying he's saying this while
indirectly supporting cancer culture
thinking it's a good thing it's a good
thing i i anything like you're talking
about former kgb anything he does i'm
not just going to take on the surface
like that's a good point thanks vlad
no there's there's something else going
okay so so please please indulge us and
let's go check that out your conspiracy
land so is it conspiracy so let's let's
play vladimir putin
seven minutes we got seven minutes
before dream team call let's talk about
that so tell us what could he be
thinking to tell americans to be very
careful with this concept of destroying
and deleting history that you had in the
past to discriminate against minorities
who are
feeling offended today
towards public renewal yeah
what's the strategy do you think putin
wants good things or bad things to
happen in america
i i think for putin and i'm being
serious with you i think for putin
uh
he is a guy that's so confident in his
abilities to lead
that and when he sits against anybody
he doesn't think anybody is at his level
because the way their government is
formatted
it's set up in a way that he doesn't
have competition versus he looks at
countries like america naive because
they actually think the person you vote
for president actually runs the country
he thinks this system is ludicrous
that's what i think of putin he controls
all the levers there that's what i'm
trying to say so i don't think putin's
sister wants to destroy america i just
think he looks at americans and he
thinks you guys are so naive that's how
he looks at america well you don't he
definitely doesn't want good things to
happen in america he doesn't want
americans to be involved but he doesn't
want us to all get along
but i actually think i actually think
at the same time i don't think
all advice he gives is manipulative i
don't think all answers he gives is
manipulative i don't because go flip it
flip it and say so go to russia imagine
you're living in russia
okay you officially became russian
overnight
40 years you've lived in russia okay
what do you think about trump
what do you think about biden what do
you think about america do you think
every word that comes out of trump's
mouth is to hurt russia do you think
every word that comes out of biden's
mouth has to hurt russia do you think
every word that comes out of obama's
mouth bush's mouth reagan's mouth has to
hurt russia do you think that's what the
every president from america is thinking
if you're russian yes
every word no okay so i don't think this
is one of those situations i think he's
concerned
that this
they may try to like make this a normal
thing in his state as well and he's like
listen pump your brakes we're not going
to play this you think he's just
speaking
on behalf of a man's man right now
he's just trying to be a man's man this
is what i i think he's really giving
good counsel that's not gonna be taken
and i think that he's saying this
knowing that and that that in that way
he's kind of looking down at it saying
like oh these guys what are they what
are they doing like look at look at them
they're they're just playing this out
and it's not going to be good so no i uh
what are norwegians thinks about
vladimir putin i mean he's your neighbor
norway is the only nato country that
borders to russia yes that's why
interestingly enough uh no i think
there's with um with russia there's no i
haven't been in norway in a while but uh
from my understanding it's it's a
interesting relationship it's somewhat
stable uh they do have they've had like
some military exercises but then
they typically do that whenever nato has
military exercises as well in norway so
it's kind of a it's like a an
ice relationship kind of you used a
really good analogy one time about putin
because
look they're the largest country on the
on earth are they not
russian yes i don't think they're a top
10 economy i'm not even sure if they're
a top 20 economy at this point it seems
like
putin is playing with like a pair of
sixes
while you know the united states has a
full house and he's still trying to like
figure out how to win that hand of poker
and he's uh he's trying to stack the
deck any way he can okay but i do think
one last thing here at least uh i do
think that
for him he needs
somebody
somewhat stable america i don't think
he's trying to strengthen america but i
don't think he wants america to crumble
and be the next afghanistan like because
you need because america to some extent
brings law and order to the world for
better or worse and you think putin
wants that i think he wants i think i
think chaos no i don't think so because
i think that's just it's just so
unstable at that point i don't think
that's what he's trying to go for i
think he's got nukes he'll figure it out
yeah he's ready for war at any point i
think he and g are in a bit of a
relationship and g is gonna say the same
thing that vladimir putin is and i i
would argue that all of a lot of the
things that we're facing now have come
from
countries like
russia and china there's videos that go
back several years of ex-kgb spies come
out and say you know the greatest thing
you can do to america is ideological
subversion china's put almost a billion
dollars into american universities i
mean they're trying to sow discord
within the united states the way you win
the war and never fire a shot right
so i think you're right i think they
want chaos and i think he's trying to
stand tall put the brakes on and say
this isn't going to happen here in
russia i think g would say the same
thing and i think i agree i don't think
he's going to let that happen in russia
but i think it's something that people
in america ought to pay attention to
because there's a lot of credence to
what he's saying
unpack the statement what part of his
statement is not actually true
unpack the statement what he said
history
history has a good point on the surface
yes yeah on the surface the statement
i'm just judging this degree motives of
course is to protect your country can we
and can we do chappelle in three minutes
sure okay
bill maher defense dave chappelle knocks
critics everyone needs to netflix and
chill the f out fox news story netflix
has stood behind the closer which
critics have decried as transphobic over
remarks chappelle made supporting jk
rowling and the gender is based in fact
declaring himself on team turf
trans exclusionary exclusionary radical
feminist
the special has caused a steer among
some netflix employees who have slammed
their employer for back in chappelle
what the f was that the reaction mars
said everyone needs to netflix and uh
chill out really dave's uh
special is offensive but not the show
where the koreans murder each other for
money mara quipped uh referring to the
hit netflix series squid game mars
audience seemed uh still seemed timid to
react to his remarks on the subject he
warned them well get used to this
because we're going to be talking about
it a lot here we can't be afraid to
speak in america he added freaking bill
maher give your thoughts
are you kidding me go pow love what bill
maher is doing more power to you buddy
this guy's
one of the scariest people in america
today is bill maher to the left yes
here's a guy that's been supportive of
the left they're sitting there saying
bill why aren't you supposed to be on
our side it's like no
you i'm going to talk about like these
things that he's talking about he said
yesterday he said um
he said this a couple months ago in
august i think he said for the longest
time i would always make fun of
conservative comedy i said there's no
place for conservative comedy you can't
do conservative comedy he says because
dennis miller who's a great comedian
tried to do comedy making fun of nancy
pelosi for 10 minutes you can't make fun
of nancy pelosi for 10 minutes he says
but sarah palin i can make of it because
nancy pelosi is not dumb sarah palin is
actually his words he called her a
which you know agree or disagree that's
his words but he said today
liberals have gone so far to one side
that if there's ever been a time to have
comic and comedy making fun of the left
today's the season because you're doing
it to yourself this is one of them yeah
your thoughts on this since you're in
the world you know as a former comedian
i've hung out with joe rogan before i've
hung out with dave chappelle multiple
times i've never hung out with bill
maher but he is definitely on my like
top five people that i would love to
hang with and learn from these are the
these are the people that i look at as
someone who has identifies as a democrat
or whatever you want to call me i love
bill maher i love dave chappelle i love
even a rogue and who's a liberal slash
conservative whatever he is
dave chappelle cannot be canceled
it's not going to happen
uh i did a poll on my instagram story
and i said can dave chappelle be
canceled 99 said no
i mean
i'm gonna put that on twitter okay
it's not going to happen i mean what
person and i think he's getting a lot
like the word transphobic
like
the
phobia phobic it's a fear of something
it's like a hate mongering theme that's
not what he's doing
what i even when i used to do stand-up
and what i love about dave chappelle
it's not racist if you make fun of
everybody yeah equal opportunity anybody
can get it white people black people
latino people trans people gay people
jewish people catholic people christian
people anyone can get it and that's the
point that i think we're missing just
because he's off limits nothing's off
limits just because he's talking about
your people doesn't mean he hates you no
okay if you've ever seen chappelle show
and when he does the player haters ball
he's done
entire skits about just hating on people
it's funny it's humor you're not
going to cancel dave chappelle and 99.9
percent of people agree with me
nothing in comedy's off-limits and if
you're a good comedian you're a chronic
button pusher
all right you're always one of them do
you have any thoughts on this that's
just the biggest thing that stood out to
me was the last point
he's been in yeah bill maher sorry do
brain fart has been in the news every
week for the past couple weeks on the
statements he's made right and every
time you go watch his audience they have
no idea what to think he's on fire right
now but they and they don't know what to
do they don't know whether to support
him to go again
right they're completely lost this goes
back to the joe manchin thing the
democratic party has no idea what
they're doing right now or where to go
what direction to go when you have
vocal people like this saying listen the
the these people on the left are getting
a little too crazy and i'm a democrat
i've said it before you've got to call
out your own side right vamanos
great gang we had a great time uh
congrats to the rookies who got on third
time you're not a rookie this is a third
third fourth this is your third or
fourth fourth or fourth okay good stuff
man i'm glad we did this and david you
crushed it man your searching abilities
is on a whole different level back
there's misspellings yes thank you thank
you thank you fantastic any
announcements you want to make leading
up to the thursday danielle de martino
will be on the podcast the great
danielle de martino put in your calendar
she'll be on uh it's going to be a fire
and i think zenner may be on as well
that's that's right episode 99 99 next
week we're gonna have the special
hundred we may do it on tuesday we may
do it on thursday we have some friends
coming in it's gonna be fun there's
gonna be giveaways there's gonna be so
put it in your calendar next week we're
gonna do it next week but one of the two
days i'm gonna announce it on thursday
whether it'll be tuesday or thursday for
next week we'll be 100 episodes take
care everybody have a great uh have a
great week we'll see you in two days bye
bye bye bye
you